if you're a Porsche fan this is probably
a place you've always wanted to have a
look inside we're with Magnus Walker
this is your downtown LA not just
workshop but garage and your personal
collection can you show us around sure
let's take a little walk let's start
with the center row the turbo row what I
call turbo fever so all these cars in
here are yours
these are ones that you keep yes
basically to clarify you know I'm a
collector driver builder I don't build
customer cars I'm not an independent
performing shop I'm just an enthusiast
and as you can see that looking around
this room yeah this is what I call an
out-of-control hobby stick inspiration
is everywhere as you see on the wall you
know a lot of my design inspiration and
influences from the late 60s and early
70s so basically I describe myself a
little bit as a mixed master I pull
these areas of inspiration which we're
surrounded by essentially throw them
into the blender pick out the bits that
I like and out comes my builds you know
and how come some very modified cars but
also that you have some very classic
looking almost stock looking cars here
yeah I mean I fell in love with Porsche
as a kid in 1977 London olds caught
Motor Show that story's familiar I'll
rush the story because I know we only
have a limited amount of time but these
are first generation 3 liter turbo cars
the turbo came out in 1975 1975 Porsche
built 284 of these what's interesting
about these two causes this is a
left-hand Drive example this is a right
hand drive example right Porsche only
made 17 right-hand drive turbos in 1975
this is the first ever right-hand drive
car I've actually ever owned when I was
in England might being British yeah when
I was in England I didn't have a
driver's license I left England at 19
never on the car there so these are
mostly stock other than being slightly
lowered and very special with these ones
the front row is like a modified row you
know you said earlier on I'm known for
customizing and building these outlaw
cars
here's perhaps a car my favourite car
number 277 started life as a 71 911 T
it's a car most associated with because
it's one that's been featured in the
majority of my video
and magazine articles and very much of
colors isn't it red way yeah you know
for me I'm an English kid
living in LA I've been here for 30 years
but growing up I watched a lot of
American TV Dukes of Hazzard Starsky and
Hutch of course Captain America and of
course Evel Knievel so I like to bring a
lot of those color design elements into
my builds this car did start in 2009
it's been an on again-off again project
it's a 1967 ASUS my usual sort of sport
purpose readable track build but with a
few new elements you know the sort of
defining feature of this car is the
front louvered fenders and this is
something that even Porsche had never
done on a curved steel louvered fender
sure they've done a louver on the 1979
17 lamang winning car but these are
individually stamped into the fender one
by one so my buddy rod Emery who is the
356 outlaw essentially he was the only
guy that could do this job and he had to
start by scanning the fender because the
louver with that radius didn't exist in
the past I've done a lot of these Hot
Rod der Lubbe deck leads where it's a
flat louver so rod scan the fender and
then he made a custom billet aluminum
die of the same radius and then it was a
matter of just establishing the center
of the fender punching the hole slitting
the line and then each individual louver
II stamped out from the underside so you
have to imagine understand the fenders
turned upside down two guys are holding
it and then one guys positioning it and
you do have to make sure that the
perpendicular and equally spaced because
once it's stamped in it's there forever
it's a beautifully detailed job there
are some other details in this room that
just sort of tell me a little bit of the
story about you and your cars what I
want to pick up on is the tires we have
some over there some on the shelves
behind you a lot of times basically do
you go through them quickly I'm a little
bit of a tire hoarder I'm one of those
guys I don't ever throw anything away
you know I always say get out and drive
pedal to the metal but that does come at
a price you know and so I do tend to go
through a lot of rubber tires you know
my theory so long is around and hold air
they're still good so I never ever throw
anything away but uh it's the price of
going pedal to the metal and that is
still the passion that's the driver
behind all of this yes and I think yeah
I mean for me the ultimate thrill is the
drive it's a freedom out there I
I live around the corner and I walk to
work so that's how I keep my carbon
footprint low and for me in all honesty
80% of my driving is pure pleasure I
don't commute to work in traffic because
to me that's not driving it's commuting
I pick the time that suits my schedule
usually very early in the morning and I
go blast through the canyons or my
favorite roads and to me it's the
ultimate freedom and it's also for me
it's like working out it's my therapy
because I'm in control of the car
whatever speed I want a driver and
that's the challenge of getting the most
out of these cars which are essentially
for the most part 40 or 50 years old you
just involved and connected with the
vehicle itself and it's a mechanical
experience and ultimately that is what I
love about driving and hopefully that
art will never ever die cuz that's my
thrill it's my drug it's my religion so
I always say get out and drive pedal to
the metal